I have become death
destroyer of worlds
what led the mild-mannered polymath who
was more interested in philosophy than
War to utter those famous words on a
single day in 1939 Robert Oppenheimer
explained how a star implodes when it
runs out of fuel
simultaneously on that same day John
Archibald wheeler published the first
explanation of atomic fission and Hitler
invaded Poland today we're going to link
them all together and talk about
America's Prometheus Robert Oppenheimer
brought nuclear fire down to a planet
that was not prepared for what the
atomic age would unleash
the destroyer of worlds
I suppose we all thought that one way or
another
welcome to the quantum Revolution where
Minds converge to reshape the fabric of
reality among those Brilliant Minds a
young Prodigy emerged a man who had
later become an enigma and a tragic
Trailblazer
this is the story of Robert Oppenheimer
As Told By Me Brian Keating an
experimental physicist with a deep and
abiding interest in the history of
Science and what better time to take us
on a deep dive into physics and
filmmaking but on the occasion of the
release of the wonderful film
Oppenheimer by Chris Nolan we'll be
talking about the time when the secrets
of the quantum realm were First
Unleashed upon the world and what it
would mean for the future if this had
never happened
Our Story begins in 1922 when
Oppenheimer a prodigious Harvard
graduate with a Fascination and a
bewilderment with the emerging field of
quantum mechanics set foot on European
soil his pursuit of the atomic Secrets
had taken him all the way to the
University of gottengen where the
quantum Revolution was in full swing
under the guidance of his advisor the
Titanic Max born Oppenheimer learned the
rules of the atom and how those rules
would reshape the planet and he began
the journey into the enigmatic world of
the subatomic particle the peaceful
inter-war years were good to him he
blossomed and after returning to the
United States in 1928 oppenheimer's
academic career blossomed he joined the
faculty of the University of California
at Berkeley rapidly gaining recognition
for his brilliance his eclectic
interests range from astrophysics to
Nuclear Physics spectroscopy to Quantum
field Theory collaborating with his
young brilliant student Heartland Snyder
he envisioned a cosmic phenomenon that
would play a role many decades later in
Christopher Nolan's other great
physics-based film Interstellar the
genius Duo developed mathematical models
that described how when a massive star
exhausts its nuclear fuel the inward
pull of gravity becomes overwhelming
causing the star to collapse in on
itself resulting in an incredibly dense
region of space where gravity is so
strong that nothing
even light can escape its crushing grasp
you guessed it a black hole the idea was
so wild and even offended Einstein's
delicate sensibilities
Oppenheimer built Berkeley's program in
theoretical physics to be one of the
best in the world and he became known as
the founder of the American School of
theoretical physics
although he had a reputation for being
arrogant he was a patient and beloved
mentor and he garnered the respect and
admiration of his students and
colleagues allowing him to leverage
their talents as well as his
Oppenheimer could selfishly have stayed
focused on theoretical physics and
Academia
fate intervened
as the world plunged Into Darkness with
the outbreak of World War II
oppenheimer's scientific expertise was
sought after to confront an
unprecedented threat the rise of Nazi
Germany and their potential to harness
the power of the nucleus for Destruction
weighed heavily on the minds of many a
physicists as the war raged in Europe
the world divided many of oppenheimer's
former colleagues from Europe were
caught up in the turmoil loyalties were
tested Jews were persecuted and many of
Europe's great Jewish scientists fled
the continent either to England or to
the United States including Einstein
Bourne Leo silard Edward Teller John Von
Neumann and Enrico Fermi troublingly
some physicists remain loyal to the Axis
powers in the German fascist State
including the quantum theorist Werner
Heisenberg
it became clear to many scientists that
based on quantum theory and discoveries
in nuclear physics
that atoms could be split
and a new and extremely powerful weapon
could be built if the Allies could
harness the item though so could Nazi
Germany some like Edward Teller foresaw
the creation of an even more powerful
weapon a super bomb based on nuclear
fusion using a fission reaction to
trigger the necessary energy conditions
but that's a film review for another day
Refugee physicists knew firsthand the
consequences of Nazi aggression and were
the first to become alerted to the
terrifying prospects of Nazi Germany
building a super weapon first
in August of 1939 they persuaded Albert
Einstein to alert President Franklin
Roosevelt of the threat in a famous
letter that grimly warned
it may soon come possible to set up a
nuclear chain reaction in a large mass
of uranium by which vast amounts of
power and large quantities of new
radium-like elements would be generated
now it appears almost certain this could
be achieved in the immediate future an
extremely powerful bombs of a new type
May thus be constructed these words
persuaded President Roosevelt in less
than two years the entire planet though
would be engulfed in a world war
later on December 7 1941 the United
States was drawn in to the conflict
owing to the fact that attacks on Pearl
Harbor by Japan and the US was almost
alone in fighting a two-front war in
Europe against Nazi Germany and in the
Pacific against imperialist Japan
America had to make the bomb first in
order to end the war before the Nazis
died oh my God scientists were assembled
and committees were formed in a race to
build the atomic bomb had begun in the
New Mexico desert a city-sized compound
emerged a place called project y was Los
Alamos but all that anybody knew it was
Project y Los Alamos it housed the
brightest scientific Minds in the world
including the very famous Richard
Feynman who recounts his exploits there
and many of his popular physics books
they worked tirelessly to construct the
first atomic bomb Oppenheimer you might
guess would be an unlikely choice to
lead this project but he proved to be a
charismatic and Relentless organizer he
built a team of extra ordinary
individuals pushing the boundaries of
what was thought possible working
alongside him was an officer in the Army
Corps of Engineers Leslie Groves who had
just completed his duties supervising
the construction of the world's largest
building the Pentagon Groves was ready
for a wartime assignment overseas but
instead he was tasked with the
Monumental feat of creating the
Manhattan Project grubs knew he needed
to recruit the best scientists in the
country and he got what was considered
to be an unusual choice for a partner
the elite Berkeley Professor Robert
Oppenheimer with no administrative or
military experience he's a general and
I've got all the soldier I need the duo
formed a brilliant pair Oppenheimer
quickly grasped the importance of the
project and he helped to inform grubs of
who would be the greatest scientist to
recruit he scooped them from Academia
and Industry few could resist his
Charisma his quiet confidence he
transformed himself into a bookish
theoretical physicist into an organizer
a confident leader and a Relentless
recruiter by April 1942 Oppenheimer and
Groves had constructed an entire
city-sized compound in Los Alamos
building a town dedicated to the
construction of the atomic bomb over 8
000 physicists chemists metallurgists
Engineers staff military personnel
security and family members occupied a
top-secret facility during the War I
single post office box famously known as
PO Box
1663 serviced over 300 buildings in Los
Alamos the nation's best and brightest
in physics work together under enormous
stress to build the first atomic bomb
but how did it work a few months after
the initiation of the Project Enrico
Fermi produced the very first Chain
Reaction a process a undergoing
sustained nuclear fission it was
understood then and there that a super
bomb could be made and detonated but
what is nuclear fission the key process
that enabled the atomic bomb and today
enables nuclear power fission occurs
when there's enough energy to shatter
apart a nucleus when the shattering
takes place the daughter the fragments
that emerge have less mass energy than
the original Parent particle had
this process cannot be triggered by an
ordinary proton or an electron because
they like the nucleus itself are charged
no instead to sneak through the coulomb
defenses the electrostatic repulsion of
the positively charged nucleus that
requires a very special actor indeed the
neutron the neutron which you last Saw
on this channel in the video entitled
neutrons die in 15 minutes is an
unstable particle that comprises the
innermost sanctum of the nucleus but
they can also be used in isolation
dislodge and fragment a heavier more
ponderous nuclear parent particle and
there is a deficit and that deficit in
energy between the parent nucleus and
the daughter nuclei that come out is
converted to Pure gamma ray energy heat
and that heat is what causes either the
destructive force of an atomic bomb or
the slow heating process used to boil
water in a steam turbine when used for
peaceful purposes in a fission reactor
sustainable nuclear fission is only
achievable under special condition
neutrons must be prepared and they must
be beamed to hit the nucleus with enough
energy and frequently enough such that
they induce a reaction that in turn
release more high energy particles that
can bombard more nuclei and so on and so
on and so on a chain reaction good
I know our nuclear reactor Works some
elements have properties that can
sustain such a nuclear reaction these
fissile elements have a large enough
Neutron multiplication factor in other
words how many neutrons are produced and
each time the parent nucleus gets
bombarded by an incident Neutron that
they can produce a sustained Chain
Reaction this occurred in 1942 by Enrico
Fermi and his team at the University of
Chicago underneath their football field
uranium is one such prospective fissile
material ingredient as we've explained
in other videos elements can have
different numbers of neutrons in their
nucleus forming what are called Isotopes
the same number of protons and electrons
but different numbers of neutrons and
different Atomic weights but only the
uranium-235 isotope has the elusive
Neutron multiplication property useful
to make it into visible material but
uranium-235 only makes up one percent of
the naturally occurring uranium one
because that's the lowest number
separating it from the more profligate
the more numerous 238 isotope is one of
the greatest challenges of the Manhattan
Project to obtain just a few kilograms
of the purified uranium-235 required the
construction of a massive industrial
scale processing facility at Oak Ridge
Tennessee employing 75 000 people at its
peak one of our famous UCSD professors
Harold Yuri the namesake of ucsd's Yuri
Hall our chemistry Department developed
one of the techniques used to enrich the
uranium from uranium-238 to uranium-235.
this process that he developed is called
gaseous diffusion
64 kilograms of enriched uranium was
constructed at Oak Ridge and ultimately
used in the first atom bomb dropped on
Hiroshima but it was early realized by
the brilliant scientists of the
Manhattan Project they couldn't make
enough uranium-235 this was a key
gripping plot Point as you may have
noticed in the movie as well a second
element proved to be as well
plutonium-239 which could be created
from uranium-238 but it's one Atomic
unit heavier so it must capture an extra
Neutron that's called a breeder reactor
many questions needed to be answered
could a chain reaction be controlled
enough to achieve detonation how much
physical material would be just right to
achieve critical mass could a bomb be
made that was small and light enough to
be delivered on an airplane how much
force was needed to be exerted to
achieve a chain reaction in a bomb
design what would be the radioactive
side effects would there be dangers to
the crew dropping the bomb and what
about a fusion super bomb how could that
be built Weighing on the scientists
working on a Manhattan Project where the
moral and ethical questions of creating
and deploying a weapon with the
potential to engulf the entire planet in
nuclear fire to produce the precious
plutonium-239 another massive complex
was constructed in Hanford Washington it
was used to create the very first atomic
bomb ever detonated in the Trinity test
Trinity used an implosion Design This
was the second nuclear weapon and the
last to be used as we'll see it required
a mere 6.2 kilograms such was its
Advanced destructive power over the
Iranian bomb Oppenheimer and Groves
relentlessly drove their teams to
produce two different designs overcoming
seemingly endless theoretical and
practical obstacles laying in the
background was always the concern of
secrecy and security for the fear was
the Nazis or the Japanese would get this
device first and perhaps steal it from
the scientists themselves or their
family members Trinity shook the world
as the first atomic bomb exploded its
mushroom cloud became a harbinger of the
immense power unleashed scientists were
overwhelmed with emotion and Oppenheimer
quoted those famous words I uttered at
the very beginning of this video I have
become death the destroyer of worlds
from the bhagavad-gita
while the development of Trinity and the
atomic bombs came too late to end the
war in Europe Germany had surrendered
two months earlier the war in the
Pacific was still raging but by now
Japan's fate was sealed
to rapidly end the war in the Pacific
preventing horrific casualties on both
sides estimated to be up to a million
American and Japanese soldiers and
civilians President Harry Truman made
the order
to develop and drop two bombs on Japan
only the newly designed and specially
modified B-29 flying fortresses were
capable of delivering these giant bombs
after extensive planning and training a
small team of scientists from Los Alamos
volunteered to be deployed at Great
risks to themselves and assemble the
bombs on the small South Pacific island
of tinyan to support the 509th group of
b-29s commanded by Paul Tibbetts on
August 6 1945 the United States
detonated an atomic bomb over the
Japanese city of Hiroshima
[Music]
three days later a second bomb was
dropped on Nagasaki the aerial bombings
killed between a hundred and twenty nine
thousand and two hundred and twenty six
thousand people most of whom were
civilians
the Japanese would not end the war for
another three weeks but the legacy of
the atomic bomb persisted Oppenheimer
the father of the atomic bomb was
initially hailed and praised as the most
famous scientist and a hero but his
conscience always wrestled with him what
were the ethical implications of nuclear
weapons in the immediate aftermath of
World War II the Cold War unfolded
suspicions and accusations marred many
scientists reputations including
oppenheimer's as well Oppenheimer was
always circumspect about the use of
nuclear weapons science has profoundly
altered the conditions of man's life
both materially and in ways of the
spirit as well along with colleagues
warning about the moral implication of
using atomic bombs many warned of the
spread of nuclear weapons in particular
to the enemy of the Cold War the Soviet
Union Oppenheimer never apologized for
the use of atomic weapons in World War
II but he did argue for international
controls after the war Oppenheimer
accepted a position as the Director of
the institute for advanced studies
joining Albert Einstein and Freeman
Dyson my very first guest on into the
impossible podcast a Shadow of Doubt was
cast Over oppenheimer's loyalties and he
was ceaselessly investigated and
surveilled by the FBI and the Deep state
as the Cold War commenced and the Soviet
Union got the bomb there came the Red
Scare McCarthyism and the House
Un-American Activities Committee
hearings oppenheimer's loyalty and
reputation were attacked no proof there
was a spy at Los Alamos but he stood his
ground and continued to serve in many
government advisory roles requiring a
security clearance but in 1954 a
grueling and controversial four-week
Security hearing led to him being
stripped of a security clearances and
his role in government ceased he
remained justifiably bitter about this
assault on his Liberties and reputation
for the rest of his life yet in April
1962 the U.S government made partial
amends for the treatment Oppenheimer
suffered during the McCarthy years
President John F Kennedy invited him to
the White House and in 1963 president
Lyndon Johnson awarded Oppenheimer the
highest honor given by the atomic energy
committee known as the Fermi award
Oppenheimer died of throat cancer just
four years later February 18th
1967. today the legacy of Robert
Oppenheimer and the Manhattan Project
indoors calling for a Manhattan Project
level of effort is synonymous with
getting the best and brightest on board
to tackle the greatest imaginable
challenges
the risk of nuclear war is greater than
ever with nine countries possessing over
000 nuclear weapons the promise of
nuclear energy has been sullied by the
problems of radioactive waste and
proliferation despite it being one of
the most promising if not the most
promising solution to global climate
change
the pursuit of understanding the nature
of reality through quantum mechanics
indoors the insight gleaned by
Oppenheimer and colleagues during the
Manhattan Project provided a foundation
for a new generation of physicists to
understand the nature of reality through
quantum mechanics and new branches of
theoretical physics are coming online at
ever accelerating rates with great power
comes great responsibility harnessing
the atom led to Humanity's ushering in
of the atomic age of nuclear energy but
also of nuclear proliferation we today
live under the threat constantly of hair
trigger nuclear warheads and we must
remain Guided by wisdom and compassion
not unlike that of J Robert Oppenheimer
up in a Hammer's story is a tale of
Brilliance ambition responsibility power
but also betrayal and regret
oppenheimer's colleague John Wheeler
once quipped we live on an island
surrounded by a sea of ignorance as our
island of knowledge grows so does the
shoreline of our ignorance so as we
navigate the uncharted waters of the
quantum and unravel the secrets of the
universe may we like Oppenheimer strive
to use this knowledge for the betterment
of humankind the banishment of ignorance
and the preservation of our fragile
tender Planet Nolan's film is out now
and it is spectacular get a ticket it's
not very often you get to see a film
where the main star is a physicist and
join us on our next Cosmic Voyage as we
dive deeper into the wonders of the
cosmos and the infinite frontiers of
human knowledge and Imagination until
then remember always be curious if you
enjoyed this video please click here for
a playlist curated just for you about
experimental physics and cosmology
[Music]